follow me
[Music]
[Applause]
Beyonce celebrating daughter Blue Ivy's
Renaissance tour debut it's pretty
amazing Beyonce shares a touching
tribute to the 11 year old on Instagram
writing in the caption my beautiful
firstborn I'm so proud and thankful to
be your mama you bring us so much joy my
sweet angel I'm just blessed yep the
sweet surprise played out on Friday
during these Renaissance tour stop in
Paris the proud mama stopped in the
middle of the song my power to quote
give it up for blue
in blue she twinned with Beyonce in a
matching sequin jumpsuit nailing the
moves alongside mom and the dancers in
front of 80 000 fans
this makes me proud but this isn't the
first time queen bees Renaissance tours
made waves last week B jumbled her words
during her performance of heated
[Music]
yeah the queen has her moments too and
the Beehive helped her get right back on
track
[Music]
despite the slip up Beyonce didn't miss
a beat and when E.T recently chatted
with her dad Matthew Knowles he
reflected on how she sets the bar so
high Beyonce is one of the best
entertainers in the world if not the
best today uh and you know she always
surprises me she always takes it to a
higher and higher and higher level but
giving back to her fans
I think everyone walks out very very
surprised very fulfilled that reminds me
that album Destiny fulfilled they walk
out very fulfilled she's a true
Entertainer I just feel so powerful and
I feel I feel fortunate that God has
given me this gift
[Music]